[Music]
in order to be Irreplaceable one must
always be
different don't spend time beating on a
wall hoping to transform it into a
[Music]
door there are people who have money and
people who are
rich
the most courageous Act is still to
think for yourself
aloud adornment what a science Beauty
what a weapon modesty what
[Music]
Elegance fashion is not simply a matter
of clothes fashion is in the air born
upon the wind one ints it
it is in the sky and on the
[Music]
road a girl should be two things classy
and
[Music]
fabulous I only drink champagne on two
occasions when I am in love and when I
am
[Music]
not the best things in life are free the
second best are very very
[Music]
expensive a woman who doesn't wear
perfume has no
future where should one wear perfume a
young woman asked wherever one wants to
be
kissed dress shabbily and they remember
the dress dress impeccably and they
remember the
woman a woman has the age she
[Music]
deserves you can be gorgeous at 30
Charming at 40 and irresistible for the
rest of your
life a woman who cuts her hair is about
to change her
life
a woman can be overdressed but never
over
elegant a woman with good shoes is never
ugly Elegance does not consist in
putting on a new
dress I don't know why women want any of
the things men have when one of the
things that women have is
men if you're sad add more lipstick and
[Music]
attack fashion changes but style
endures the best color in the whole
world is the one that looks good on
you
women think of all colors except the
absence of color I have said that black
has it all white
too their beauty is absolute it is the
perfect
[Music]
harmony fashion has two purposes comfort
and love beauty comes when fashion
[Music]
succeeds
Elegance is when the inside is as
beautiful as the
outside some people think luxury is the
opposite of poverty it is not it is the
opposite of
[Music]
vulgarity Simplicity is the keynote of
all true
[Music]
Elegance I don't do fashion I am
fashion dress like you are going to meet
your worst enemy
today fashion that does not reach the
streets is not
[Music]
fashion my life didn't please me so I
created my
[Music]
life
Elegance is not the prerogative of those
who have just escaped from adolescence
but of those who have already taken
possession of their
future I don't care what you think of me
I don't think of you at
[Music]
all success is achieved by those who
don't know that failure is
inevitable
you live but once you might as well be
amusing gentleness doesn't get work done
unless you happen to be a hen laying
eggs Hard Times arouse an instinctive
desire for
[Music]
authenticity how many care ears one
loses when one decides not to be
something but to be
someone there is no time for cut and
dried monotony there is time for work
and time for love that leaves no other
[Music]
time if you were born without wings do
nothing to prevent them from
growing
nature gives you the face you have at 20
life shapes the face you have at 30 but
at 50 you get the face you
deserve youth is something very new 20
years ago no one mentioned
it since everything is in our heads we
had better not lose
them
as long as you know men are like
children you know
everything I am not young but I feel
young the day I feel old I will go to
bed and stay there Jim Lai I feel that
to live is a wonderful
thing one shouldn't spend all of one's
time dressing
all one needs are two or three suits as
long as they and everything to go with
them are
perfect fashion is made to become
unfashionable it's always better to be
slightly
underdressed luxury must be comfortable
otherwise it is not
[Music]
luxury fashion is
architecture it is a matter of
proportions a girl should be two things
who and what she
[Music]
wants men always remember a woman who
has caused them concern and
uneasiness
only those with no memory insist on
their
originality if a man talks bad about all
women it usually means he was burned by
one
[Music]
woman I wanted to give a woman
comfortable clothes that would flow with
her body a woman is closest to being
naked when she is is well
dressed I've done my best in regard to
people and life without precepts but
with a taste for
[Music]
justice